do you have to look at the docs every
time you make a plot in Python using a
precise grammar helps you build and
describe plots there's a whole book
about the grammar of Graphics itself but
the theory is basically that you layer
data Aesthetics GMS facets statistics
coordinate
themes you can use a grammar of Graphics
in Python with the plot 9 package this
grammar allows you to make and describe
any plot
no matter what it looks
like start by loading in your
data add your data to your grammar of
Graphics
[Music]
plot next add your Aesthetics like X and
Y
[Music]
variables then add GM shapes such as
points these will be applied to your
Aesthetics